hey wassup guys my name is a channel of
episode 6 of Les mag flappy bird today
we'll be talking about loading dashes
into our game as well as buffers since
we want to be able to use textures in
our game we need a way to go from an
image file to something that can be
displayed on our screen the workflow is
pretty simple firstly we need to load
our image file then we'll grab pixels
from that image and finally use them to
create an OpenGL texture there are a few
things to pay attention to in this
process and we'll address those things
as we write them let's make a class
called texture which will represent a
texture that will load I'll put this
into a package called graphics since it
refers to the graphical aspects of our
game we'll need to define a few fields
to hold important information such as
the width and height of the texture and
the ID that OpenGL will assign to the
texture when we created this ID will be
used to activate our texture when
rendering I call this field texture but
you can call it ID if it makes more
sense to you let's make a constructor
that takes in a string this will be the
file path of our texture we'll leave it
blank for now we'll make a private
method that also takes in a string again
being the file path this will be a
rather large method that will
essentially do everything from loading
the file to creating the OpenGL texture
it'll return an integer
being the OpenGL ID for the texture
which we need to assign to our field
firstly we'll use a buffered image to
load our image file using image IO read
with a file input stream this will throw
some exceptions so that's around that
line with a try and catch we can get rid
of the file not found exception since IO
exception includes that again handle
them properly if you wish we're gonna be
keeping it simple if the image file is
loaded successfully we'll have all the
data we need in our buffered image
object so let's set width equal to image
get width and then do the same for
height we'll create an integer array
called pixels that will contain all of
the pixels in our image with each
integer in the array being the color of
the pixel and the index of that integer
referring to where the pixel is located
in our image inside the try block we'll
set the size of our pixels array to be
the size of our image as soon as we find
that out now let's call image get RGB
with the appropriate parameters
including our pixels array arrays in
Java are passed by reference which is
why get RGB doesn't need to return
anything it will simply set our array
through the parameter what we have now
is an array of pixels which makes up our
text
before we can give it to OpenGL though
we need to change the format of it to
comply with what OpenGL wants basically
we just need to move some bytes around
each color in our pixels array is
represented as a RGB alpha red green
blue
that's the order of our color channels
because that's how buffered image loaded
in our pixels if we look at an example
color in hexadecimal format what this
essentially means is that the leftmost
two digits represent the Alpha Channel
then the red green and blue Channel
whilst we can tell OpenGL to use a
variety of formats
none of them suit this one the easiest
and most practical to adjust to is RGB a
or a BG R if we read from left to right
so as you can see we need to move around
the ordering of channels luckily this
isn't too difficult to do if you know
what you're doing first let's make a new
integer array called data which will
store this new format of pixels
obviously it will be the same size as
our pixels array now we need a for loop
that will iterate through each of the
pixels in our array since each colony's
to get reformatted for each of these
colors we need to extract each Channel
which can be done by masking using the
bitwise and operator and then shifting
it the appropriate number of bits to get
it to the rightmost bits to start for
example let's take a look at the Alpha
Channel it's the leftmost Channel so we
need to end it by FF 0 0 0 0 0 0 which
will preserve just the required bits and
finally move it to the right since each
of these hex digits represents four bits
we need to move at a total of 24 bits to
the right the leading zeros have no
effect just as they wouldn't with a
decimal number so we're left with just
the Alpha Channel nice once we've
extracted all the channels let's put
them back together in the correct order
to comply with our new format the Alpha
Channel will go back to where it was and
no change then we'll use the bitwise or
operator to combine the other channels
next blue will go to where read used to
be green will stay where it was and red
will take blues old place now we've got
our new array data populated with pixels
though in the right format for OpenGL we
used a lot of bitwise operators in bit
level calculations here so make sure you
research and understand them I might
make a dedicated video in the future
explaining them in depth
since there
quite important in graphics programming
the last step is to use OpenGL to create
this texture from our pixels firstly
we'll statically import GL 1:1 now let's
generate a new texture and assign its ID
to text for now to activate this texture
for use
we need to bind it using GL bind texture
it's a 2d texture
hence the texture 2d flag will pass some
text since that's the ID of the texture
we want to select now that it's selected
we can modify and use it think of this
like selecting a layer in Photoshop or
any other similar program we can't
modify it if it's not selected before
blue feed our pixels into this texture
let's set two important parameters
basically what this will do is disable
anti-aliasing for our textures we'll be
dealing with some lowest resolution
graphics particularly for the bird and
we don't want those textures to be
blurred if our game runs at a high
resolution
this will keep our textures nice and
sharp as I mentioned two episodes ago
lwl doesn't want a raise it wants
buffers we'll need a way to convert
arrays into buffers let's make a new
utility class for this we'll need this
quite frequently we'll pop it into our
util package and call it boffin utils
LW j GL actually has a very similar
class but our one is going to be
slightly different this will be a static
class so once again once at a private
constructor in this series we'll need to
use byte buffers float buffers and of
course into buffers for the pixels we
just created let's create a static
method which takes in a byte array and
returns a byte buffer don't forget to
hit control shift or O to import things
as we'll be doing this throughout the
series will create a byte buffer result
and allocate a new direct buffer with
the same size as our array we'll set the
order to be native order which is what L
dubba JGL wants next we'll put the
arrange of the buffer and flip the
buffer for it basically flips the buffer
and prepares it for reading again
something L w GL wants that's all we
need to do to go from array - l w GL
compliant buffer let's duplicate this
method twice and adjusted for use with
float and in buffers the only real
difference here apart from changing the
types and appending the as float or int
buffer is the size of the allocated
buffer since we're still technically
allocating byte arrays to begin with the
size needs to be in bytes 1 byte in java
takes up 1 byte however floats and
integers both take up 4 bytes which is
32 bits
because of this we need to multiply the
size of the array by four or shift left
two places which is mathematically
identical to multiplying by four and
that's our buffer utils class back in
our texture class lists use this new
functionality will call GL techs image
2d setting a format to be RGB a the
width and height to the appropriate
values the type of data to be GL
unsigned byte and finally feeding in our
data array by calling buffer utils to
create in buffer data you might
accidentally be using the l w GL version
of buffer utils so scroll up to the top
and make sure that you're not you need
to use the one you just created note
that we use GL unsigned by as the type
colors are essentially unsigned bytes
many they range from 0 to 255 inclusive
Java unfortunately doesn't have unsigned
types and Java is signed by it is rather
useless to us since it ranges from
negative 128 to positive 127 inclusive
because it can't store anything above
127 and we need to we have to use
another data type such as int sure it
would have also worked what I chose to
use ends finally will unbind the texture
since we're done with it and can now
deselected so that we don't accidentally
use it in the future
we'll return our text integer which
holds our ID and we are done
our textures are now ready to use in
OpenGL I'm going to go ahead and add
getters for the three fields we have
since we'll need to access them in the
future particularly the ID I'm also
going to go back up to the constructor
and assign the texture field to our load
method with the path as the parameter
and that's it our texture class is done
we can now easily use it to load images
into our game and use them as OpenGL
textures fantastic thanks for watching I
hope you enjoyed the video as always a
like is greatly appreciated next episode
will be rendering an object onto the
screen goodbye